في بلاد راقصي السامبا،
نشأ طفلا فقيرا معدما، لا يجد قوت يومه
، فقد أخذ منه الفقر النصيب الأكبر
، واختار أصعب الطرق للوصول إلى هدفه
، وبدأ حياته بائعا للفول وماسحا للأحذية
هذا العامل البسيط، وصل بجهده إلى سدة الحكم
، ونشر العدالة والتنمية، تآمروا عليه وسجنوه
، فخرج بريئا من المحكمة
(لولا داسيلفا، للقصة بقية)
عندماولد الطفل لولا دا سيلفا، عام ١٩٤٥
مكث والده بعد ذلك أسبوعين فقط ثم سافر مع ابنة عمه
وعندما ظنت أمه أن أباه قد وجد عملا لحقت به
لكنه كان قد تزوج بابنة عمه بعد قصة حب بينهما
، وهنا انتهت حكاية الأب ،،
وبعد أن اكتشفت أم لولا خيانة زوجها،
عاشت في غرفة صغيرة هي وابناءها،
ورغم عيشها في فقر شديد فقد كان جل اهتماها هي نشأة وتعليم أبنائها،،
ويقول لولا عنها،
لقد علمتني أمي كيف أمشي مرفوع الرأس
وكيف احترم نفسي حتى يحترمني الآخرون
بدأ لولا دراسته في سن الخامسة
لكنه لم يستطع إكمال دراسته وتوقف عند سن العاشرة
بسبب الفقر الشديد، وهنا بدأ الكفاح،
فعمل في مسح الأحذية، وعمل بائعا متجولا للفول السوداني،
ثم عاملا في محطة وقود، وعامل تعدين.
وميكانيكي وبائع خضرة، فازاد الفتى صلابة في ظل هذه الظروف،
لكن براعته جعلته يتخصص في التعدين فكسب دورة لمدة ٣ سنوات
، تفانيه في عمله جعله يفقد إصبعه الخنصر في أحد المصانع التي عمل فيها،
وبسبب هذه الحادثة عانى لولا كثيرا ليحصل على العلاج،
فعمل في نقابة عمالية اهتماما منه وتفكيرا
بحق العمال، ونال منصب نائب رئيس النقابة بسبب اجتهاده
وفي عام ١٩٨١
حدث إضراب للعمال في ساوباولو،
فارتجل لولا خطابا وشجع العمال لأخذ حقوقهم،
فسجن لمدة شهر، ثم حكمت عليه المحكمة بالسجن ٣سنوات،
لكنه خرج من سجنه في العام التالي،
(الطريق إلى الرئاسة)
بعد خروجه من السجن، شارك لولا في الانتخابات الحكومية
لكنه خسر، لم ييأس وشارك في الحملة الانتخابية
ل أوليسيس غاماريس بعد عامين.
وحققوا نجاحا ملفتا،
سنتين فقط وانتُخب لولا نائبا عن ولاية ساوباولو،
ليشارك بعد ذلك في صياغة الدستور
وفي عام ١٩٨٩
تمت أول انتخابات رئاسية بعد الإنقلاب ورشح لولا نفسه لكنه خسر،
هل سيستمر لولا أم سيتوقف بعد خسارته حرب الانتخابات للمرة الثانية ؟
باختلاف المناصب في المرتين،
واستمر لولا في موقعه في الحزب، وفي عام ١٩٩٤
أعاد ترشيح نفسه لكنه خسر من الجولة الأولى
، وعاد ورشح نفسه عام ١٩٩٨
ولكنه خسر أيضا من الجولة الأولى
، وخلال ذلك أصبح قويا في حزبه حزب العمال المعارض
واستمر الحزب بالنمو وهو الذي تأسس عام ١٩٨٠
علي يد لولا داسيلفا وعدد من المثقفين والسياسيين،
وفي عام ٢٠٠٢
ها هو لولا ينجح أخيرا في الانتخابات الرئاسية بعد ٣محاولات فاشلة
ثم استطاع النجاح بفترة رئاسية أخرى عام ٢٠٠٦
(الطريق للعدالة)
خلال فترة حكمه كرس لولا جهده لتحقيق العدالة الاجتماعية
ورفع اقتصاد البلاد بعد التضخم الذي شهدته البلاد قبل حكمه
، وأقنع رجال الأعمال بالالتفاف حول الفقراء والمحتاجين،
كما وضع الكثير من البرامج الاجتماعية التي ساعدت في تقدم البرازيل إلى حد كبير
وبفضله عاشت البرازيل نموا اقتصادي كبير
وصارت الدولة الأعلى اقتصادا في دول العالم الثالث.
بفائض يزيد عن ٢٠٠ مليار دولار
، وبعد أن كانت الدولة في فقر شديد جعلها لولا في المرتبة الثامنة
في أعلى أقتصادات العالم،
وبعد انتهاء فترة حكمه الثانية رفض لولا تعديل الدستور
ليضيف فترة ثالثة رغم حب الشعب له،
وقال .. ناضلت قبل عشرين سنة
، ودخلت السجن لمنع الرؤساء من أن يبقوا في الحكم أطول من المدة القانونية
. كيف أسمح لنفسى أن أفعل ذلك الآن
وهذه الكلمات اللتي قالها لولا دا سيلفا
كافية لشرح أسباب تفوق بعض الدول عن غيرها
وإلى هنا وصلنا إلى نهاية هذا الفيديو